hello everyone
my name is gregorville snap and be
talking about some joint work with the
nurse dua and symmetric arithmetic
circuits specifically lower bounds for
symmetric circuits for the determinant
so the brief summary of what we're going
to be talking about today
previously in an ico paper indian icon
2020 we introduced this notion of a
symmetric arithmetic circuit
and we proved
an exponential lower bound for the
permanent in this model and a polynomial
upper bound for the determinant
and the notion of symmetry in this
context requires that the circuit remain
essentially unchanged under simultaneous
row column permutations to the input
matrix of variables so we have a matrix
of variables as input at the top of the
circuit and we allow simultaneous row
column permutations of that matrix and
each permutation needs to extend in
autos in the circuit needs to keep the
circuit unchanged
and in the paper today the paper i'm
going to be talking about today we
introduce a more stringent symmetry
requirement
namely we discussed the action of the
alternate group on the rows and columns
of the matrix separately
and in this model we prove an
exponential lower bound for the
determinant and this important this
importantly contrasts with the
polynomial upper bound we have for the
other symmetry group
now a42ri this gives us an exponential
lower bound for
um symmetric circuits relative to the
full symmetric group of the determinant
right which is a sort of more
in some sense more natural groups
considering the determinant case and we
get a nice lower bound
it also establishes an exponential
separation between two distinct and
interesting symmetric arithmetic circuit
models in other words different uh
symmetry models for different groups
it sort of establishes the importance of
considering these two different groups
um the result is that it requires a
substantial new machinery so this
includes developing new game-based
characterizations as well as new ways
constructing um particular types of
matrices using uh cypher iman
constructions and a whole host of other
things so there are a lot of new
developments in this context
um and most importantly perhaps
at least hopefully in the long term
uh this result involves developing an
entirely novel framework around how to
analyze symmetric circuits
relative to some different group the
result is that we can now study symmetry
as a sort of resource and ask questions
about how symmetric a circuit needs to
be before we can prove something bound
so i'm going to discuss circuits very
briefly so everyone should be familiar
with these so a circle is just a dag
structure and here on the left hand side
you can see the input gates in green and
the internal gates in blue and red
and
in the boolean context we ordinarily
have input gates labeled by variables
and internal gates labeled by boolean
functions internal input gates goes to
be labeled by zero one
and the idea is that a boolean circuit
computes a function in the following way
we take some input and assign them to
the input variables and then recursively
evaluate each gate in the circuit until
we finally evaluate the output gate and
that's the value of the function
and in this way a family of circuits can
define a language
in the arithmetic context things a
little bit different
it was well it was noted that a large
number of algebraic problems can be
reduced to the problem of computing some
polynomial or indeed more accurately
family of polynomials and in this
context we consider circuits that are
slightly more syntactic
in the way that they're that we approach
them in particular we generally don't
the input gates in this context can be
either variables or elements from some
field not just zero one
and we ordinarily don't replace the
variables with elements of the field and
evaluate rather we just evaluate
recursively evaluate through the gates
and treat the operations at each gate as
field operations so as sorry as ring
operations in the polynomial ring so
ordinarily the gate's labeled by plus
and times
and we can just recurse as normal but in
this case again we don't really replace
usually with values
in this way each uh
each gate defines some polynomial and
the circuit as a whole defines some
polynomial at the output gate
now
in this context um perhaps the two most
important functions that anyone
considers are the permanent the
determinant
um so valiance conjecture the analog of
the p versus mp problem the vp versus
vmp problem
is equivalent to proving uh
exponential lower balance on the
permanent
and indeed the permanent determinant and
in contrast the determinant is
um
perhaps two most well-known functions in
this context are the permanent of the
determinant
the permanent is complete in vnp
making it one of the hardest problems
that we tend to consider in this context
and the determinant is complete albeit
in a different sense in vp
and as such the vp versus vnp problem
the analog of the fpv mp problem is
often reframed as the permanent first
determinant problem why is it the
permanent seems so much harder than the
determinant
and so proving lower bounds about either
of these functions is a
proving well lower and upper bounds but
proving lower upper bounds for
perhaps the two most important functions
perhaps the two most important functions
in this context are permanent and the
determinant
the permanent is the canonical difficult
function it's vmp complete and the
determinant is
not quite it is vp complete albeit in a
different sense and as such the vp
versus vmp problem which is the problem
of separating these two complexity
classes the algebraic analog of the p
versus np problem
is often reframed or thought about as
the permanent first determinant problem
why is it that the permanent seems so
much harder than the determinant and
indeed you can see below how these two
functions are defined the determinant
and the permanent seem very similar in
structure the determinant just has this
additional sign flipping
and so it's a sort of great mystery to
try to prove exactly why it is that the
permanent is so much more difficult to
actually compute
um and a lot of work goes into trying to
understand these two functions
now one approach to understanding them
is to look at restricted circuit models
and the reason for that is that we don't
really have any super polynomial lower
bounds for general arithmetic circuits
computing the permanent or indeed
for the determinant but in determining
this case we have upper bounds um so we
tend to restrict to compute to to
establish them in terms of some
restricted classes so a very famous
example is there's no sub-exponential
family of monetary arithmetic circuits
computing the permanent or the
determinant and the same for depth three
arithmetic circuits although here we
have to put restrictions on the field
now what we're introducing or indeed
what we introduced in ical 2020 is a
generalized is a
a symmetric circuit model so a model of
what it means to be
a model of symmetry in this context
so we say a circuit c is g symmetric
if the action of each permutation sigma
in g on the input gate extends an
automorphism of the circuit
let me
give a somewhat concrete example so here
we have a circuit where the input gates
are labeled by x y and z
and we want to consider this the actor
the you know to what extent the circuit
might be symmetric
so let's consider
uh
just the transposition x y
now if we were to transpose x y does
this does this uh uh permutation
extension all from us to the circuit and
it's not too hard to see that indeed it
does if we swap those two gates we just
need to swap those other two blue gates
and indeed we have an automorphism of
the circuit so this circuit is symmetric
with respect to the group generated by
that transposition
it's not too difficult to see that
indeed this particular permutation the
one in yellow doesn't extend an
automotive circuit so this circuit is
not symmetric with respect to any group
that contains sigma 2.
so before i move on i need to discuss
this previous work on arithmetic so on
symmetrical arithmetic circuits the
in this work we have two two main
results we have a lower bound for the
permanent which establishes that for
every field of characteristic other than
two there's no family of some and
symmetric arithmetic circuits over f
um
of sub-exponential size computing the
permanent and here by cement symmetric
arithmetic circuits we mean the
simultaneous action of the symmetric
group on both the rows and the columns
all right and we have a similar upper
bound here we have to consider uh fields
of characteristic zero explicitly
um
for the in this and in this case it's
for the determinant of course
and here we have a size bound of o and
four over n to the four right so we have
a nice polynomial upper bound
but at this stage
you might be asking okay great these
seem interesting but there's this some n
some why cement symmetric why
particularly this group action what
makes this interesting what makes this
canonical
and indeed in the lower in the lower
bound case
it doesn't seem to matter much
um in the lower bound case
uh a much you know
a4i this lower bound applies to any
group that contains cement so any larger
group action
which includes in particular the full
symmetry group of the permanent which
would be a which is a much more
uh natural group to consider and indeed
a whole bunch of other groups one might
consider so in the lower bound case
um you know
while the group choice may be arbitrary
it applies to all sorts of much more
canonical groups as well
in the upper bound case this is a bit
more of a problem
um and we might and certainly uh this
upper bound doesn't apply a42ri to the
uh to the full symmetry group of the
determinant
um
and so it's a bit of a tricky question
to ask to answer how why is the script
canonical
um
and indeed
what we're going to be addressing today
really carries on from that and is
you know sort of motivated by that
question so what we've done today is
proved in fact that there is an
exponential lower bound on the
determinant when one considers the
action of alt n cross alt n
um on the input gates
right so here we do have an exponential
lower bound
and now of course this lower bound does
apply a foot ri to the full symmetry
group of the determinant so we now do
actually get an exponent you know that
it is that
any family of circuits that are
symmetric with respect to the full
symmetry group of the determinant is
necessarily going to have to be at least
exponential size if it's computing the
tone
over fields characteristics there
we also get a lower bound for the
permanent a very similar low bound for
the permanent but i'm going to be
omitting details on this lower bound in
this talk
so before we go on to actually discuss
the proof techniques and
i'm going to have to you know i'm going
to have to apologize in advance for the
fact that things do get a bit technical
in discussing those proof techniques
because
in some sense that's when the meat of
the paper lies
i'm just going to briefly discuss two
utterly crucial tools
that we need to be able to prove lower
bounds
so firstly supports now any lower bound
for symmetric circuits indeed for
symmetric linear programs and all sorts
of other symmetric uh
subfield or or or
approaches in complexity theory rely on
some theory of supports
so a support for a gate g and let's
suppose this
so support for some kg in a circuit and
let's suppose the circuit has
say a matrix structure on the input
gates and let's suppose g is some
subgroup of some n
um so we have some gate g and we have
some g acting on the circuit
so a support is some subset s of m such
that any permutation that fixes s point
wise is also going to fix g
right so what exactly does that mean so
let's take a look at the circuit
and here we have some group g acting on
the uh on the input gates and let's
again assume it's that g is a subset of
a subgroup of some n
for the sake of simplicity
now
what's if if one applies g to those
input gates it's easy to see that if we
fix x1 through x4
sorry x11 through x44 and all of those
gates are input to g then definitely any
permutation that fixes those is also
going to fix g
right and as such we might say one
through four one two three four is a
support for g
right that's the sensor which you needed
so if we fix those guys over there
everything you know we we've definitely
fixed g
and indeed there's the important thing
we want to do in in
the theory of supports is prove
bounds on the size of these supports
right so what we have is that if a
family of alten across all ten symmetric
circuits
uh cn where each circuit takes it takes
it as input a matrix of variables has
sub-exponential size
then every gate in every circuit has a
support of sub-linear size
right so if the circuits are small we
have small supports
the next crucial ingredient is the
bijection game
so the original projection game this
halo's projection game involves two
players the duplicator and the spoiler
who play on a pair of graphs gh using k
pairs of pebbles now the duplicator is
trying to show these graphs are similar
and the spoiler is trying to show that
they're not the same
and the game proceeds in rounds with
three steps in each round
first in the round the spoiler picks up
a pair of pebbles ai and bi now these
might have been originally placed on the
graph or they might have not yet been
placed on the graph
on the graphs
the duplicator then picks a bijection
let's say
gamma from g to h
um such that
this maps aj to bj for everyone except
the pebble we've already picked up right
so it's it's mapping the pebbles
accordingly
and the spoiler then places the pebble
that he picked up somewhere and places
so he places the ai pebble you know
anywhere on g
and he places the bi pebble on the
corresponding vertex in h
okay the spoiler wins if a duplicator
has failed to
if gamma fails to be a partial
isomorphism between the pebbled sets
while the pebble sequences
and we say duplicate as a winning
strategy if he has a way of playing
forever
now the generalized bijection game and
before i get on to the generalized
potential game i should say
that
there's a connection there between
projection games and counting with and
indeed counting logics which i'm not
going to go into now i'm going to go
straight to the bijection game and frame
that all in terms of supports but i
would recommend reading the paper for
for a discussion of the counting with
angle or approach to describing it as
well
so in the generalized projection game we
again have the duplicator and the
spoiler
um who are playing in the same way the
only real difference is that we also
specify a particular collection of
bijections from which the duplicator can
select right so the game again proceeds
in three rounds except now the
duplicator must select from that set of
bijections
and we continue as before now what's the
difference here well
one obvious one is that if we're playing
on say pairs of isomorphic graphs in the
previous case the duplicator could
always find a function that mapped from
uh that ensured that the two graphs were
uh
that he could play forever so he had a
winning strategy
in contrast
in this context it might be the case
that the
isomorphism that the duplicator would
like to play
to to make sure he can play forever
isn't actually in the collection of
allowed allowed by ejections so it might
be that the spoiler can win for a
particular set so that's where the
distinction enters
now importantly um
and we generally don't specify
the set of ejections directly but
instead specify a single bijection from
g to h
and then a group of
permutations on g and just by composing
we get of course a collection of
bijections
and indeed in this paper we are actually
interested in often just taking a single
graph
and then taking a set of
um
uh uh automorphisms
directly
so um
[Music]
uh the connection between the two is a
little bit
long to frame
and here i framed it in almost exactly
the way we're going to use it today
rather than in the slightly more general
way it appears in the paper
but essentially the crucial thing is the
following
we have a sequence of graphs if if we
have if there's a sequence of graphs
which can be bi-partitioned into two
partitions of size n and here i
explicitly say one through n and one
through n because we want to feed these
we want to treat these as input to a
circuit and
uh so we kind of we we need to actually
have labels for the different vertices
to do so
and i'll i'll brush over the details of
how this is normally treated
and so if we have this family of graphs
such the duplicator can win the
bijection game
with
the set of projections generated by the
group all 10 cross alt n and some and
some alpha
with 2 k pebbles
then any family of alt n cross alternate
symmetric circuits that distinguish the
two the two the two copies of the two
graphs right gn and some alt g and it's
really just a different representation
of the same graph
must have gates with all supports of
size more than km in other words if the
duplicator can maintain
can uh
has a winning strategy
for the game with 2k pebbles
then it follows
that uh uh
any any circuit that distinguishes these
two
these two representations of the of the
graph must have
more than k uh supports of size more
than k right all gates must have all
supports of size more than k
in particular if you place a
uh a linear lower bound
if we can place if we can prove a linear
lower bound on the
uh if we if we can ensure that
duplicator can win the game with a
linear lower bound on the number of
pebbles
it follows that any circuit that can
distinguish between the two graphs must
also have a linear lower bound on the
size of the supports
so what does that mean if we bring it
all together
well we want to prove this being result
how do we go about it well from the
support theorem we know that any family
of some any sub-exponential size family
must have sublinear supports
so if we show
that there's a sequence of bipartite
graphs such the duplicator can win the
bijection game
with a linear number of pebbles then in
particular it follows
that the any circuit that's computing
this family must be exponential in size
so
let me go back
so what remains to do in this paper
sorry in this discussion
is um
to actually establish that family of
graphs gm and that's what the rest of
this work is going to be we're going to
be spending the vast majority of the
rest of talk
actually constructing these
the sequence of graphs gm
and then finally um playing the game
very briefly or at least sketching out
how the game is played on these families
on these on these graphs
so we begin with a construction that
might be familiar to some people the
scythiam imminent construction
and
how this works is we begin with a three
regular bipartite graph
and we construct this graph xg
by essentially replacing each vertex
with a gadget you can see the gadget
here on the right hand side so you
replace each you replace each edge with
a pair of vertices here f0 f1 g0 g1 h0
h1 and then we have these internal
vertices
now it's easy to note that xg is
bipartite and importantly we're going to
be interested in by bipartite in sorry
in by in the bi-adjacency matrices that
you can construct from this graph right
this xg
and of course to construct a by
adjacency matrix you need to choose
bijections from the different by the
different partitions in other words you
need to order each partition or to
construct the matrix
now
importantly and
reasonably straightforwardly we should
recall that if m is a big matrix of some
xg then any transposition applied to the
row or column
uh negates the determinant so if the
determinant of m is
so the determinant of m is the negation
of the determinant of n where n is
formed by flipping a two
two rows or two columns
so what we're going to be talking about
is how we're actually going to prove
right we'd like to construct remember
this family of graphs and we need to
make sure that in this family in the
sequence of graphs we're going to
construct that we're going to have one
graph gn and one graph alpha gm that
have different determinants now as i
noted a moment ago
if the determinant is non-zero
then we can construct we can take alpha
to just be a flip of a row or column and
now we have gn and alpha gn and they
both can have different determinants so
we want to find some way of making sure
the determinant is non-zero in gn
and we're going to do that by going
through a whole process of first
counting perfect matchings and showing
how perfect matchings relate to the
determinant et cetera et cetera and this
is what we're going to be discussing the
next few slides
so let's let m be the buy adjacency
matrix of some
some cfi graph
xg
we identify that perfect we identify a
perfect matching this is a perfect
matching in
xg
with a bijection a to b denoting
adjacency in other words the bijection
maps uh little a little b
if uh a and b if the edge from a to b is
in the perfect matching
and of course then just rolling out uh
the definition
of uh of the determinant right
we get that the determinant is equal to
this
this particular formula here
and what we're going to do is consider
two types of perfect matchings
we say that um a perfect matching mu is
uniform if for every edge in the
underlying graph this is the graph from
which we construct the cfi graph there's
at most one edge from a vertex in one
gadget to the other
right
otherwise we say it's non-uniform so
let's look at an example so here you can
see
that for every edge
right for every f0 f1 g0 g1 h0 h1
there's only one edge between that and
the adjacency gadget the adjacent gadget
that gets chosen in the perfect matching
so this is a this is going to be a
um
this is going to be a uniform perfect
matching and if indeed there were two
yellow lines from say f0 and f1 away to
another gadget then it would be
non-uniform
so let's look at uniform non-uniform
public matching so let's consider
non-uniform perfect matchings first
now let's suppose we have a non-uniform
perfect matching and we remove two
vertices matched outside of the gadget
right remember non-uniform project
matching is going to have two vertices
that match outside the gadget you can
see the example up here and let's
suppose you actually
remove those two vertices that are
mapped outside of the gadget
right because they're matched and we
want to consider matchings in the rest
of it now it's possible to show that in
this eight vertex graph that remains
each mapping each matching that can
appear can be paired off into matchings
of opposite science
and as such
we can actually just remove the
non-uniform matchings and really just
consider the determinant in terms of the
uniform matchings right so we can prove
that in fact the determinant is equal to
this uniform case and here by uniform xg
i mean the set of all uniform perfect
matchings on xg
so now we need to move on to actually
talking about how we're going to count
these uniform perfect matchings
so let's suppose mu is some perfect
matching in the cypher m1 graph
and let's let f mu be the set of edges
in the
underlying graph such that exactly one
of the corresponding edges
in the
cfi gadget corresponding to that
that edge in the outline graph is in mu
and let f mu be the function that
essentially tells you which one of these
two edges in the scifurman cipher
element gadget
is actually being included in the
perfect matching
now we can sort of go in reverse let's
suppose we have some two factor f and
some function f
and let mu f f be the set of all
matchings which in some sense match that
template in other words such that f mu
is equal to f and little f mu is equal
to f
right in other words uh yeah as i said
match the template in that sense
right and the theorem we have is that
the set of all
perfect matchings that match that
template so these are perfect matches in
the cfi graph that match this template
is 2 to the 2m where m is the size for
partition of g
right so to actually see this let's
you know let's take a look at a diagram
right so to see this note that suppose
we have some matching
in ff
and in that
at some get and let's particularly zoom
in at some gadget at v for some vertex v
in the line graph
and notice that exactly two vertices
must be matched outside the gadget
because remember we're interested in
uniform matchings
right so in this case let's suppose that
f0 and g0 have been matched outside the
graph
now we can delete those vertices because
we're interested in the other matching
so let's delete those vertices and now
notice we have a six cycle so if you
look at the top there if we delete f0
and g0 we in fact get that six cycle at
the bottom it's not quite a six cycle
it's a six cycle with a path leading out
of it right and it's not too hard to
notice that exactly that has exactly two
matchings
and
it follows that each vertex we can
independent and it follows then that
each at each vertex we can independently
select from those two matchings since
there are two vertices
right since there are m vertices in
particular in a partition of g
it follows that they're going to be
two to the two m perfect matchings
um that actually
that actually satisfy this template
so we now come to one of the most
important parts of the paper
establishing that in fact the cypherman
graphs for an important class of graphs
is going to have is going to have or are
going to have non-zero
determinant
for that are thereby adjacency matrix of
course
and so
what we do is show
that if a graph has an odd number of
perfect matchings then in fact
the
determinant of the cypher m1 graph
is going to be non-zero
and before we do that we need to make a
few observations so firstly it's easy to
see that 32 matchings in mu ff
they're related by an even
even permutation and so have the same
sign
it can also be shown with considerably
more work
that the sign in fact doesn't depend on
f right if we swap out f and talk about
small f here
we always get that all the graphs sorry
all the perfect matchings in that family
have the same sign
right and so now we're ready to prove
the theorem right and as i said if gn
has an odd number of perfect matchings
then the by jscc matrix of the cycle of
immigrant graph has nonzero determinant
this is the crucial result and let's
quickly go through a sketch of that
argument we recall
that since we can't cancel out the
non-uniform perfect matchings we can
write the determinant we can write the
uniform uh or we can write the uh
formula for the determinant in this way
right now let's suppose f is some two
factor and mu f be the set of all
matchings
or perfect matchings
in the template mu f
small f for any particular choice of
small f so we don't care about which
labeling function we have on the edges
it doesn't make a difference
and using the result we had previously
we can uh we can recall that we can we
it follows that the size of this set
right the set of all of all perfect
matchings irrespective of the choice of
little f
is two to the four m
right
and it's not too hard to see
following from this that the determinant
is given by this formula what do i mean
by sine f well recall that
that all the perfect matchings in muf
are going to have the psi the same sign
so sine f is just the sign of that of
any perfect matching within that class
of perfect matchings
right and this is just implementing
the above formula right
but recall that the number of two
factors in a graph that's three
regulators the same as number of perfect
matchings in fact every the complement
of every two factors are perfect
matching and vice versus you have this
bijection between two factors of perfect
matchings
and remember that set is odd by
assumption in the theorem
so it follows that that that this
summation
is going to be a summation of a bunch of
minus ones and ones
but the the the number of summons is
going to be
uh uh uh odd and so it follows that the
smart can't be the sum can't be zero
and therefore the determinant can't be
zero and that's the rough idea of help
that's the well not too rough there's
some detail there but that's the the
detail on the proof
we're not going to talk about actually
how we go about constructing these
graphs
um
that we're going to ultimately use to to
play the games on and and prove our
lower bound
now the graph constructions are going to
mostly be built around the three things
we've spoken already we need to make
sure the determinant is non-zero
so that we can
ensure that we have a pair of graph
representations with different
determinants
we need to make sure the graphs are well
built so we can use the cyphering
construction and we also need to make
sure the graphs have
meet certain conditions
um so that we can actually play the game
on them so firstly we're talking about
balanced bipartite graphs that's where
this condition comes in we need to make
sure the graphs are three regular
sciphone construction
we need the graphs to be what we call k
well connected for some
linear bounded k
and what we mean by k well connected is
that any balance separator has size more
than k
and
for the reasons mentioned a moment ago
we need gn to have an odd number of
perfect matchings and that's that's the
determinant condition
right and we would prove this by showing
that a random three regular bipartite
graph on two then vertices satisfies uh
the third condition with high
probability
and then we show that can be modified to
satisfy the fourth condition while still
keeping the connectivity condition
high right so we can still satisfy the
connectivity condition in some sense
it's still
you know we don't we might diminish k
but not so much that we lose the slowly
a low about that's the idea
right
and to do this we need to we need to use
some facts about the distribution of
three regular bipartite graphs and again
i won't go to technical detail about
what we actually did in this context but
i'll sort of just hand wave us through
well not hand wave but i'll i'll try not
to go through
too much onerous detail
okay and so let's talk about sampling
and expanded graphs so the trouble is
that something random graph and
distribution right the uniform
distribution
um
on
the uniform distribution for
three regular bipartite graphs is not
exactly easy but it is well known to be
approximated by other distributions and
so what we consider is this distribution
g n curly g n defined by the following
procedure so this is how we pull a graph
in this distribution firstly we choose
uniformly at random the bijections pi 1
pi 2 pi three right and u and v are
supposed to be
the uh two
you did the
the uh two partitions right the
partitions of this the by partitions of
this graph
and we check that these these functions
are pairwise just joined right we need
to of course ensure this so that the
resulting graph is too irregular and
if it's not the case we discard
rejections until it is the case
right and we get a graph defined as
follows
right so in other words each
edge is defined by one of those
permutations
and importantly this distribution is
contiguous with the uniform distribution
on three regular balanced by partial
graphs on two end vertices
and what that means
um is that since any any uniform in any
graph and uniform distribution is an
alpha expander with probability ten to
one we can say the same for g n and d
that's what that's what that's what uh
contiguous means in this context it
means that anything that holds almost
any property that holds up a surely for
one for one class will hold up a surety
for the other
now lastly we note
that if a graph in gn is an alpha
expanded follows that it's an epsilon n
well can it's epsilon n while connected
for some constant epsilon greater than
zero this just follows from the obvious
connection between the expansion uh uh
between
given for expanders and uh
the the balance separators in the graph
so let's next talk about perfect
matchings and
rank right so i mentioned there's that
fourth requirement
that we actually have to make sure that
we can
ratchet up
the um
it's going all the way back here
we have to be able to
sorry we have to be able to ratchet up
the number of perfect matchings
whilst not hurting the connectivity too
much and we do this
in terms of rank and let me explain how
right so we've gotten the first three
conditions using this probabilistic
argument to get the fourth we to pick a
graph with an odd number of matchings
and so let's suppose g is chosen from g
n
and let a g be the by json c matrix for
this graph or a by json matrix for this
graph and we should we should like with
high probability that the permanent of
the matrix over f2 is not zero it's the
same as saying it needs to have odd uh
it needs to have odd permanent
now why am i suddenly talking about the
permanent recall that the permanent of
the adjacency matrix of a graph
is equal
to the number of perfect matchings in
that graph right so that's the
connection while i'm starting to talk
about the permanent
so to get this oddness condition we just
need to check that the permanent as a
matrix of f2 is not zero
right but let's recall something we're
talking about f2 and the permanent at
the determinant code side of f2 so it
suffices to show that uh a g the
alternate um sorry the by adjacency
matrix
indeed has non-zero determinant
which is to say it has full rank
and how do we go about showing that this
this matrix has full rank
well we show we show this in two steps
we show that with probability bounded
away from zero the rank of a g is at
least n minus some sublinear factor
all right which doesn't quite get you
there
we also need to actually we we couple
this with another result which says that
if that if we have some graph g with
sublinear rank
we can transform it into a graph g dash
with slightly higher rank
and
g is well connected if g is well
connected and so is g dash more formally
we actually lose a little bit of the
connectedness feature but since we only
need to iterate this a sub linear number
of times we still can retain a linear
lower bound on the well connectedness
parameter
but i won't go into too many details
there
so how do we then put the graph together
well we have a sequence of bipartite
graphs we want to have a sequence of
parabolic graphs with these conditions
as we just discussed
so let m and n be two by j's and c
matrices of the cyphering
graph on gn where n is for example
formed by swapping a single row
um or a single column it should say or
not add there that's a typo
well no it has to be auro
the fourth and what this fourth
condition now guarantees is that the
determinant is non-zero for both m and n
right but of course m and n have inverse
determinants
right
and so therefore they have non-equal
determinants so now we have a family of
by adjacency matrices or we can think of
these as just
ways of representing these graphs
that have different determinants
and it now suffices to show that
duplicate is a wedding strategy in the
projection game
so how do we actually play the bijection
game
well let's first talk about what we
actually want to prove using the
bijection
so we play the projection game on two
copies of x gm so we can think of these
two copies as essentially two different
by adjacency matrices or we can think of
those two copies of the graph
where gn is chosen to have the required
four properties and we just discussed
how we can ensure that we have a geo
that has the required four properties
and with a set by set of bijections
right these are the projections we're
going to play the game with
is given by this again this pair where
the group alt n cross sorry alt a cross
alt b
and alpha
right where alpha is essentially just a
transposition
that swaps say
two elements of the you know two columns
right so alpha is what kind of
introduces this twist
um and which is what negates the
determinant
and indeed it's possible to show that
for some
uh at least linear function the
duplicator is a winning strategy in the
projection game using that number of
pebbles
right so how do we actually play the
game and again this is actually quite a
detailed argument in the paper and i
don't want to go through it i don't
think we have the time or space to
really go through it in an awful lot of
detail but let me provide something of
an overview so the important thing is to
note and it's kind of one of the crucial
factors when we're talking about these
gadgets
is that there's an automorphism gadget
that swaps the pairs of vertices in
each of two pairs
of outer vertices and fixes the vertices
in the third pair right what do i mean
by that so here's the sciphon m1
gadget floating around right
and the idea is that if if you give me
any two pairs say f0 f1 and g1 g0
right there's an automation that swaps
those two and fixes the third right so
for example here's a case right so if we
swap g1 and g0 and f4 and f1 here is the
automorphism of the group of the of the
gadget that uh that keeps those
um
that extends from that particular
those particular trans transpositions
and hc and h1 you'll notice stay still
right
an essential idea beca behind the game
uses this feature but let me discuss how
the game works
right so the idea is that it suffices
for the duplicator to maintain an
automorphism of the graph formed by
composing some transposition
say
gzog1
with a member of alt a cross old b
and we think of this transposition this
g zero g one as representing something
like a twist
in the graph or if i'm trying to be
specific in the representation of the
graph so in the matrix
right
and so the spoiler should like to reveal
by that this by placing pebbles around
the twist
and so what the duplicator does is avoid
that by essentially
hiding the twist now what does that mean
well g n is k well connected
so if you remove so removing all the
vertices corresponding to gadgets with
one of the k pebbles
still leaves us with a two connected
component delta that's at least half the
size of gm
right so we have this large two
connected component
even if we remove
all the the the vertices that haven't
pebbled by the spoiler we're talking
about the pebbles the a the a1s through
aks
so now the duplicator can effectively
hide the twist in the large component
and use the fact that the component is
too well connected to move the twist
along a cycle
and remember cycles have even length and
so this suffices for our work right we
can move between bijections
and we can do so in a way that involves
just applications of even permutations
right and that suffices ultimately now
to get our main result because now we've
played the game on the graphs the graphs
have different determinants
and therefore we've satisfied the
conditions to prove our main result so
let me talk a little bit about some let
me make a few concluding remarks so the
approach to take here not only proves an
interesting result right an exponential
separation for the determinant for two
interesting symmetry symmetry restricted
arithmetic circuit models as well as of
course proving a lower bound for the
for the
sorry proving a lower bound for the
canonical
symmetry model for the determinant
namely those circuits that are
geosymmetric
where g is the full symmetry group of
the determinant
but it's worth noting that in this talk
i've tried to be quite explicit and talk
about the ultimate cross-alt-n group
action because we only really have time
for that
but in fact the machinery that we
develop in the paper goes well beyond
that it's usually the agnostic to the
group actions not always there are some
places where it's not
and indeed it goes well beyond matrix
structures on the input right we can
talk about graphs and indeed we can talk
about really general structures just
essentially g sets being taken as inputs
um and as i said there are some
limitations of what we can prove at this
point in terms of generalization so if
we could generalize the support theorem
we'd be able to prove all sorts of
interesting results about symmetric
circuits far more general versions of
symmetric circuits
and it's important to note as well
that this approach and indeed especially
if we managed to prove general results
to the sport theorem really opens up the
opportunity to study symmetry not as
some sort of tacked on feature but as a
real resource for understanding
understanding a computation in general
right how does symmetry trade off
against computational power of the model
and being allowing us to
change the group of uh the group the
group and the action that we're
considering how the what the
how the circuit is what the circuit is
symmetric with respect to
really allows us to move along a
spectrum from the trivial group action
where we're just talking about normal
arithmetic circuits all the way to other
group actions at the top like alt m
across alt n or some n or other group
actions you might consider and it's
really interesting to think what happens
as we slide along these scale can we
begin to prove lower bounds along the
scale we already have
an exponential separation for two points
on the scale that's what
that's what's proved in this paper but
can we go further and really understand
the spectrum
that i think would be a very interesting
next step
anyways thank you so much really
appreciate your time
and i hope you all have a lovely
conference